know why leave your entries in us
already crows an episode of why no why
no why I'm looking forward to these
videos every week now because so much
things are just happening and what best
way to summarize the week by through
memes how do you get your news PD PI's
submission subreddit wait a minute are
you say 51,000 uploads this is the top
boat of all time Jesus Christ my
favorite part was when they did the
fortnight dances in the suicide forest
but instead of corpses it's dead check
really outdone themselves this year
thank you Dad for finally supporting my
channel just kidding 75 million oh my
god a kid it's at 76 guys learn freaking
math you idiots mark ass mark axe and
marques Brownlee damn I can now say I
appear in the second most disliked
youtube video of all time you didn't
deserve this mark Hayes we talked about
hurry one would be different and going
from 300 town islands to around hundred
but the edits still overwhelming it
always looks like they're trying to
please and include everyone which they
clearly can't okay that's all I got for
now go subscribe to Peter pie
subscribe to beauty pie oh yeah I posted
this on Twitter because so many people
were pointing this out but Jayden left
even more references sub to PewDiePie
and I think that's a smash letter that's
obviously the tide Logan Paul oh here we
go it's that [ __ ] lasagna no way you
gotta knock girls that's awesome and
Indian nine-year-old spent months making
this game for pits but it never got to
the Y despite three attempts 25 likes
and gold award excuse me what I didn't
see this are you kidding me oh it's Mars
yet we're still yeah I think I kept it
here shall we
[Music]
what was that
no marcia no please
I mean finally a game with good writing
goddamn where's my lasagna might see hmm
where's Marcia fun fact in Italy they
call as Anja pastitsio oh I like music
oh hey Felix who is this Oh Fran oh hey
Felix hey Brad oh you won't believe it
Felix
I saw this shadow dude who kidnapped my
chair for some reason hey I got hurt
trying to free her sure you did
oh man how are you feeling come into the
house no I'll be fine you go to the town
and try to get help to save Lexi okay
take care bread
you're always so nice and chipper as
always I feel like I have to check if
there's anything on the lamp it's very
pretty
look at the animations and everything I
love all my hey I'm collecting
oh it's good shake all right use these
guns and show them who's the boss oh I
thought there were boots few guns all
three no hey I'm collecting monetization
I say Maya
Gillard good this is amazing this is
dope I don't know how to open this this
is a puzzle I can't do puzzles come on
and I push this oh I can there you go
look at that what is that you're doing
okay what are you doing what is that
okay I have something I probably need it
for okay there we go
nice god damn I'm good at games bye bye
Edgar ah yeah ah god damn you you too
I'm sorry hey hey hey hey hey hey no no
no no it took my monetization this is
the most accurate game of all time is
this good just gonna be a play through
this game
I completely forgot that I was supposed
to do with oh why oh god ed guy grab
that the thing Thanks
I mean I didn't want to it's only a demo
but game of the year let's not jack god
damnit YouTube I'm sick of your [ __ ] god
dammit YouTube stop getting me
demonetized flex good flex time and
yours about as useless as tails and
sonic eh-eh
god damnit not like this
don't do me like this markiplier oh god
I'm dead I'm actually gonna die
stop eating me oh my god I actually died
I'm the developer of this game Gurpreet
Singh Mathur oh I thought I'd show up to
thank you for playing the game it really
means a lot to me I wish I could take
this project further and actually make a
game out of it but sadly I have to focus
on work and things that take a higher
priority that's all right anyway I hope
you enjoy the prototype I'd really love
it if you could let me know what you
have thought of it in the comments of
the game days oh and it's the chair
don't worry I won't ask for $3.99 take
it and fall into the page you'll be
teleported back to the start of the game
so that you could play with the chair
what what hell yeah
how do I activate it oh yes this changes
every I can spend I can spend goddammit
get out of my way Brad 399 10 out of 10
10 out of 10 now we got to go back into
the memes no I did not look a tutorial
cuz I got stuck okay goddammit thank you
so much that's amazing
Peter PI's second job stop sending me
look-alike pictures I know I look like
any average Swedish person on the planet
but that's racist it would be funny if
YouTube rewind got to monetize they
literally do 12-hour shoes for shoot for
a two second clip I mean how much money
do you spend an insane amount of money
on the rewind
wait I gotta show you guys you've
probably seen this Justin Bieber's baby
getting almost three hundred thousand
dislike taken up in one day do to people
what a rewind to an eighteen as the most
disliked video this is a perfect example
of how to turn the hate of another thing
into the fastest way to clear hey guys
sometimes we got to make the big
sacrifices here we got to go to the
Justin Bieber baby video that I actually
I'm curious if I actually disliked it
and we got a remove I just liked it it's
time to remove our dislikes moving on
and so it begins
youtuber PewDiePie calls little sings a
crybaby after she speaks alibi waging
inequality how about this title youtuber
PewDiePie rightfully calls out Leigh
Leigh sings because she is a crybaby
how's that for a title for a change huh
have Melbourne born Australia doing our
part hit or miss I guess they never
missed huh she recently had 5 million
subscribers can we push her channel to 6
million just because she sneaked
PewDiePie chair into YouTube rewind can
we increase the size of this channel by
1/5 just for a meme guys I mean why not
that's practically what's happening with
my channel we are doing our part in
Hungary
sub to Poots equals free muffin damn
damn
1% of the world is now subscribed to
beautify I mean obviously that isn't
right cuz there's a lot of duplicate
accounts and a lot of dead people and um
can you unrefined a celebrity in rewind
a twitch streamer in rewind a youtuber
who hasn't posted in seven months let's
make her the face of rewind a youtuber
who I made videos for almost a decade
became the most daily can I add that
daily because the most obscure you tuber
for five years donated to Indian 9 year
olds but still not in rewind this is so
sad where was y'all at when I was in the
what the freaking frack happened to your
office I'm gonna add some stuff to it I
uh I'm just trying to figure it out
don't worry don't worry okay stop
complaining very underrated comment it's
called you to rewind because the quality
keeps going backwards every year
journalist writing articles about Puetz
be like reality can be whatever I want I
mean 100% accuracy meme status everyone
going through some hard times so I
wanted to draw something to make Felix
laugh hopefully long you did you
actually did that's great thank you very
much I would never say the N word though
it's I don't understand dear Peter pie
your time of darkness will reveal an
unlikely ally the Logan is coming not
the hero we wanted but the hero we need
I kind of like how you know despite
people's differences people can still
come together to fight TV series YouTube
really doesn't care about our troops why
I wasn't in YouTube rewind this year
Dane now you step too far YouTube Dane
wasn't in YouTube rewind disgusting Dane
is a hero now just to be clear I don't
know if Dane is a Nazi I haven't done
facts checks I haven't done background
checks just want to be clear on that
all grown up PD by 9 3 2 5 14 what's up
my 14 year olds Jayden animation
sneaking pills into rewind is proof that
youtube doesn't quality check their
content or review it I can't believe
YouTube shouted out PewDiePie this is
pretty pison I see youtube rewind added
pip ice chair YouTube is a Nazi s MH
anyone else think Jaden deserves a chair
[Laughter]
Takashi six nine four meme review Jaden
for meme review it looks like the
subreddit has found a new girl to
fangirl over sorry sorry sky Lola I
guess I guess they forget don't they a
video for youtube rewind Jayden
animation PewDiePie references everybody
you can't supple can I copy strike
YouTube rewind yes yes you can we must
make this happen guys PewDiePie is not
included in YouTube rewind 2018 Jayden
animation infiltrates PewDiePie chair in
the video PT Pike there it is there it
is copy striking YouTube for including
his match blaming all the revenues
can I copy strike YouTube rewind hmm mr.
Bies Wow
okay animal abuse likes move on yes more
Will Smith means please that's
definitely good name the media when
pewds donate to charity the media when
pute dozen oopsie sort of give the
benefit of the doubt but i mean
obviously they don't have to post about
the charity that we did i think it's a
cool story overturning hate into
something positive and also doing a good
thing but it seems like they're so
caught up that i have to be a villain so
they can keep click baiting all these
articles with me in a negative way that
it's just never gonna change
i think this was a good example of that
because it just went completely
unnoticed and also now with the the fake
anti-semitism for me recommending a
video the end channel that i like i mean
it's just
we'll see maybe it's time for the empire
to strike back Peter price sets a new
world record
every time he gains a subscriber that's
true actually thank you adventure time
penguin Gunter is a good day I don't
remember
petition for PewDiePie to host a special
meme of the Year episode of meme review
as his last video of the year I was
actually gonna do this I thought a nice
little reminiscence of all the memes
this year would be very nice
hi Felix we just wanted to ask um bides
is doing oh we wish you to only the best
9 year old she's doing great thank you
for asking justice she's got her own
brand myyy working on that right now
and that's taken up all our time
petition to remove legs from the new
subreddit icon this meme has gone too
far this joke that I don't have legs is
no longer funny I have legs beauty would
you turn them against me you have done
that yourself Petey pyres shout out to
hateful anti-semantic YouTube channel
hello excuse me that's gloria borger AKA
a funny little side mean the one who
wrote that article
unnhhh ironically tweeted something like
I'm not gonna add my opinion about this
but here's my opinion about this media
using hundreds of pictures of Petey pie
on internet for their articles every one
every goddamn article has this goddamn
picture of me I mean I guess it could be
worse but that's haha I was in this year
rewind as a blur in the background how
does that look like I was promised a
special role after flying 15 hours
sacrificing missing the cube event me
naked a bunch of craters filmed 8 to 10
hours
see this is the usually the experience
they they could shoot this so quickly
and so easily but there's YouTube has so
much money they just say hey let's just
spend the whole day and it goes down to
like a two second clip hentai heaven
subscribe to be a PI or we delete this
attention all gamers in order to defeat
t-series once and for all
PewDiePie needs your help smash that
subscribe button like I smash every day
god damn amazing I cannot thank you guys
enough for all the support
honestly it means so much this is so
funny anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did smash like you
know what else to do I don't even have
to tell you now at this point do I but
yeah see you next time bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]